I if the next president were to ask me
the matter I would caution that person
thinking it's getting overly involved
first I don't think it is as important
as it's made out certainly not enough
important enough for the Palestinians
ever to make any real compromises on the
issue if you want something badly enough
you'll make compromises even if they're
kind of unpleasant and in 2000 we
demonsaw the palestinians walked on the
core issues in dispute they will not
compromise so it's not that important to
them maybe but it's important that
presidents not do things that presidents
can't do and it's important the
presidents do not promise to solve
problems that they can't solve the time
of a president is an extraordinarily
scarce resource and when somebody comes
along and says I want you to devote a
hundred hours or 200 hours to problem X
that is 100 to 200 hours that is not
available for Nageotte dealings with
Congress over the budget for the
environmental problems for other foreign
policy problems and we saw that in the
Clinton years with this the
palestinian-israeli dispute just became
a time sink for the President of the
United States and in the end it was a
failure and that would it was the
President Bush stayed away from this
issue for so long not just for
ideological reasons but above all
because he was very conscious you could
just spent hours and hours of time and
achieve nothing look at what had
happened to President Clinton so I would
say that America's attitude toward there
should be a much more laid-back one
there may come a moment when the parties
are ready for a compromise either
because the Palestinians feel defeated
or because the Israelis do until that it
is harder for the United States to want
this peace more than the parties
you